welcome back local elections are coming
up this week the prime minister's out
campaigning in hartlepool in the
northeast of england today and he's just
given an interview to broadcasters let's
have a listen in
look at what uh has happened in that
year that you talk about when i i came
here uh with jill in hartlepool and look
at look at the uh the investments that
have been uh that have been coming in uh
ge building turbines at t side the
freeport now uh going gangbusters uh the
investment by the saudis in in in
hydrogen uh the the gigafactory uh
oblive uh look at what look at the new
investments that we've seen in that time
uh just in that period in uh in
sunderland that the northeast is is see
you're seeing nissan the the envision
gigging factory you're seeing massive
investments in cutting-edge technology
in the northeast uh by the way the area
of the of the uk that exports the most
per capita uh investment in jobs that
will last decades decades and decades
and
i think that what we're also seeing is
investment in by the by the government
and stuff that really matters to people
another 764 more police out on the
streets since we were here last time
helping to to bring crime down and uh
sending since the government began and
helping to bring neighborhood crime down
absolutely indispensable massive
investment in gigabit broadband in
schools
infrastructure skills technology are the
tools by which we will continue to get
on with our agenda of uniting and
leveling up and i'm very proud of what
we're doing in north
[Music]
i certainly think that it's crucial that
the government
fixes
our energy supply issues and the energy
spike the spike in energy prices is a is
a global phenomenon but it's but what we
haven't had is the national solutions
that the country can deliver and that
the people of this country deserve this
is the country that first split the atom
we're looking at 1960s technology this
stuff is as old as i am but what when
what we want to do
is to make sure that we
we modernize and we build a reactor a
year rather than a reactor a decade now
what that will do is it will give the uk
the kind of uh
resilience the kind of self reliance the
security that we need for our energy
supplies that other countries have look
at switzerland look at france where the
inflationary pressures are lower because
they have their own dependable sources
of
clean
low carbon energy that's what nuclear
provides that's what offshore wind
provides by the way and the northeast is
fantastic also uh for offshore wind so
why is it taking 12 years
put this investment in place
you've been in government 12 years where
have you been it's been a short sighted
well i it you're you're very kind to say
that i've been in government for 12
years i i i i spent most of my time uh
running uh running london but what where
what we're doing
what
it was the labour party in 1997 that
said there is no future there is no
business case for nuclear nuclear power
in this country that was the disaster
that was the disaster and what it takes
i'm afraid quite a while to get a new
nuclear reactor going but we're going to
do it we're going to build a reactor a
year rather than a reactor every decade
and what we want to have here is uh
advanced modular reactors cutting edge
technology what what they what they the
advantage of the amr is it produces
superheated steam very very hot steam
which is useful for making hydrogen and
a lot of other things
we are we are looking at
not just one but several amrs on this
side
or adjacent to this side not here but
adjacent